un seul de ses 14 aventuriers succèdera
à lionel qui a remporté les 450 euros
une somme folle
de la tarde de folie on a grimpé un
petit sketch 3 c'est un festival de
vannes c'est complètement fou les
pronoms tête vous bien c'est seul moyen
de faire du poids rapidement c'est pas
possible entre les les cas sociaux les
débiles
tu es vraiment chez les dingues tout est
possible ça qui est génial et
j'ai adoré meilleur comme le pire mais
moi j'adore le pire évidemment du
vitrail
on peut à mon avis clairement profité et
regardez le flambeau sans avoir vu la
fable c'est sûr mais si vraiment vous
avez aimé la flamme vous allez adorer le
flambeau qu'est ce qu'il est devenu
l'animateur de la flamme pour les manger
le vrai concept que qui lui plaisait il
à déjà c'était d'imaginer constate irisé
une émission de télé réalité différente
à chaque fois vous êtes sûr que cela
parce que ya pas de vilains barak ne
sais même pas où il revient me revient
sur une autre émission de télé réalité
car mike est rien on va te construire
nous-mêmes te construire avec quoi anne
nos mains peut-être ils pensent que
c'est toujours une émission de dating
donc il croit toujours qu'il va trouver
l'amour laventure moi une aventure d'un
soir ça me va très bien et il comprend
pas il sait quoi cette émission de merde
qu'on ne sait pas du tout ce qu'on fait
pour l'instant c'est n'importe quoi
l'émission ouais je crois que le gros
gain c'est de se dire une bonne série
c'est qu'on a envie de retrouver les
personnages on avait le sentiment qu'il
ya des personnages qu'on a envie de
retrouver que l'on va faire un petit
exercice d'accord c'est pas ça
l'exercice et puis à tous ces nouveaux
personnages ont émergé qu'il n'y avait
absolument pas tomassi mais kad merad le
rappel par an
zarb arbres la jungle dating jambes
l'accord ce que si jonathan
j'ai
bien dormi il faut bien briller ça
faisait longtemps que j'avais pas fait
une bonne grosse
connerie au puc et xo sauvegarde sa fin
ce qui me séduit sellal aventure en fait
[Applaudissements]
parce qu'il verrait en fait moi c'est
justement ces équipes qui ne se
connaissent pas qui doivent proposer les
uns avec les autres il ya forcément des
antagonismes votre contribution ils
savent très bien qu'ils passent à la
télé ils savent très bien les codes moi
c'est pas du profil par confère donc en
vrai il on joue pour certains fait
semblant de m'énerver ce matin c'est
exactement ça qui fait réagir les gens
sur les oiseaux c'est plus centré sur
moi s'est centrée sur tous les
personnages et je pense que c'est ça
aussi qui va apporter beaucoup de
diversité puis de renouveau aussi par
rapport à la saison la
patrie ça me plaît l'idée que ce soit
très border no censure de toute façon
canal pour le coup ils sont vraiment nos
potes là dessus mais non et encore de la
place
aujourd'hui pour des séries loufoque
dingue et c'est ça qui compte parce que
c'est ça qu'on a besoin d'avoir dans le
panorama français
[Musique]
quel sera le prochain aventuriers
éliminés vous le saurez en regardant le
prochain épisode du flambeau